-Welcome back. Big show.
Bad Bunny is here tonight.
Yeah. And before --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Bad Bunny.
Before I bring him out,
I just want to say quickly.
Last night I went to the Blue
Note here in New York City.
Great club.
Robert Glasper is there.
If you get a chance
to see him,
he's there
for the rest of the month.
So I guess you have another week
or week and a half.
He's unbelievable.
I know you went, Quest, right?
-Of course.
-Yeah. He's unbelievable.
Who's the deejay that...?
-I forget.
-Is it --
-Jahi.
-Jahi. He has a deejay.
He's playing jazz.
But they're also sampling stuff.
It's amazing.
It is, dare I say, avant garde.
[ Audience oohs ]
-Oh.
-It was unbelievable.
So, anyways, just --
he just crushed it.
So shout-out to Robert Glasper
and his band.
Thank you. That was amazing.
-Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Jimmy! Jimmy!
Hang on. Hang on.
-What's up?
-I didn't know
we were doing shout-outs.
Can I do one?
-Yeah, sure.
Go ahead. Give a shout-out.
-Can I get some shout-out music?
♪♪
Alright.
It's your man, Questo.
And I just want
to give a shout-out
to my Impossible cheesesteaks,
alright?
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's the food of the future.
Alright.
The meat may not be real,
but it tastes Questacular.
-Questacular. I love that.
Great shout-out, Quest.
Great shout-out.
-Yo, yo, I got one, Jimmy.
-Okay. Come on. Go for it.
-Shout-out
to silica gel packets.
I'm gonna be honest.
I don't even know what you do,
but I love opening up
a bag of beef jerky
and seeing your weird little ass
hanging with all that meat.
-Thank you. That's good.
Thank you. Thank you, Kamal.
It's very good.
Thank you. Kamal.
I appreciate it. Anyway --
-Hey, hey.
I got -- I got -- I got one.
-Oh. Higgins. Sure.
Higgins, let's hear it.
-Okay. Ready?
Shout-out to to-do lists.
-Oh.
-Keeping me schedule on track.
Do my laundry. Check.
New milk. Check.
"Wat-- Watch out for anvil"?
[ Laughter ]
-We'll find out
what that one means.
That looked real.
Anyway --
-I got one, Jimmy!
-Oh, Tariq. Sure.
-Yeah, yeah.
Well, shout-out to October.
You know, when the air is crisp.
-Oh, yeah!
-Of course.
The air is crisp.
The leaves are getting turnt.
And you know I'm all about
making my own pumpkin bread.
So don't be an oaf.
Whip up a loaf!
-What are we gonna need?
-Well, you're gonna need butter,
a little sugar, some flour.
Of course you need a pumpkin.
You mash those bitches
all together,
and then you got to do
my favorite thing of all.
Get baked.
-Alright, well,
that sounds delicious.
I think I'm gonna make that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think I'm gonna make that
for my family.
-I don't care
what you do with it, Jimmy.
-Alright. Very good.
-Can I -- Can I do
a shout-out, Jimmy?
Can I do a shout-out?
-Of course, sir. Let's hear it.
-I'd like to do a shout-out
to that person
in the middle seat
of the airplane
who gets to use both armrests,
you know, the whole time.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
The person in the window
gets all the beautiful views
of Cleveland.
-Yeah.
-Person on the left,
on the aisle over here,
they get to get up
and go to the bathroom two times
an hour if they want.
-Yeah.
-But the person
in the middle seat,
the little snuggly,
little cuddly,
little spoony spoon seat...
they get to -- they get to
play little elbow games
with the other people
the whole time.
All flight long.
-All flight long.
-♪ All flight long ♪
-Oh! Wow!
Well, that's a great shout-out.
I'm gonna try that sometime.
-I got a shout-out.
-Oh. Great. Go ahead, sir.
-I got a shout-out. Yeah.
Shout-out to wearing suspenders
underneath your shirt.
Yeah!
-Wow.
-It keeps your pants up,
keeps your waistline clean.
Suspenders under the shirt
for the win. Dab!
-Uh...
That's a good look.
Thanks, bud. Appreciate it.
-I've got a shout-out, too,
Jimmy.
-Oh, go for it, James.
-Shout-out to wigs.
I love wigs so much.
They make me feel like
a whole new person.
Don't believe me?
Check this out.
Say goodbye to James...
and hello to Josh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
James.
Josh.
[ Chuckles ]
Man, I could do this all day.
-Good. I like Josh.
I like Josh, too.
Alright, so we got a shout-out
to Impossible cheesesteak.
Shout out to silica packets.
Shout out to to-do lists.
-Yeah.
"Sec-- Second anvil"? What?
-Uh, shout-out to October.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Shout-out to middle seats.
Shout-out to suspenders
under your shirt.
Shout-out to wigs.
And shout-out to Robert Glasper.
And the Blue Note Jazz club.
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with Bad Bunny, everybody.